BUILDING.
FULL BUILDING TONIGHT.
>> Craig: SUCH A NOTICEABLE
>> Chris: NOW THE SECOND U WAST
THIS TIME.
BUT WATCH RIELLY A
NICHOLAS ROBERTSONSUPPORT.D HES
MAYBE THOUGHT OF GOING BACK.
THEN HE SAW BUNTING GET
AGAINST BUFFALO.
NYLANDER TO WORK.
CROSS-ICE.
RIELLY CAN'T T
>> Craig: NICE JOB WITH MRAZEKD
LINE.
FIRED THAT THE ROAD.
HE'S GOT 11 GOALS IN 12 GAMES.
>> Craig: SEEN ALL THROUGH THE
FIRST PERIOD AS WELL.
THERE'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE. PRETTY.
BUT SHOT NEVER MATERIAL
OLOFSSON AND NOW DAHLIN ACROSS.
AND IN AND BAD
BREAK AS THIS SHOT DOESN'T GET
IN TO MR LOOKING
INTENT ON TRYING TO SNAP A
>> Craig: GOALTENDERS TURNED IT.
BRYSON ON THE MOVE AGAIN. HAS T.
THAT TOOK A HS GAME T
REMEMBER THIS SEQUENCE FOR PETR
MRAZEK.
THERE'S THE PLAY BY SKINNER.
NOW HE WINS THIS
SO HOLL AND SANDIN HERE. STUCK
ANDERSON WHO LOOKED BACK OVER
ANDERSON.
CHCHNER.
WE MENTIONED BEFORE HAVING A
BREAKTHROUGH SEASON AGAIN.
GO B
>> Chris: EIGHT TIMES A 20-GOA
JOIN THE TWO OFNE LOOKS
IT'S BEEN THE BEST I'VE SEEN THE
BUFFAL